bienvenue dans cette seconde vidéo
concernant les annonces de disney
avant-hier nous avons passé en revue
toutes les nouvelles annonces concernant
star wars et du coc bat aujourd'hui on
passe à marvel et je vous avoue que ça
me hype beaucoup surtout que beaucoup de
projets ont été décalées voire reporté à
cause de évidemment la crise sanitaire
on passe le bonjour à black widow si
elle passe par là bref juste avant de
commencer je tenais à vous informer que
vous étiez beaucoup à regarder la chaîne
sans être spécialement abonnés c'est le
moment de le faire
si vous ne souhaitez louper aucune des
prochaines vidéos et il va y en avoir
plein vu la quantité d'annoncer qu'il y
a voilà n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre
allez commençons je vous propose de
parler de toutes les annonces dans
l'ordre chronologique de leur sortie
nous avons tout d'abord rwanda vision
prévue pour le 15 janvier 2021
cette fameuse série post in game
réunissant les personnages de wendat
maximov la sorcière rouge ainsi que
vision ne va pas rentrer dans les
détails je vous ai déjà parlé en
profondeur de la série dans une récente
vidéo pour le 19 mars 2021 nous aurons
la fameuse série sur the falcon and the
winter soldier une bande-annonce a
également été partagée et le concept est
intéressant
tout d'abord tout comme one la vision
c'est une série composée de six épisodes
c'est vraiment du contenu à se mettre
sous la dent en attendant les gros
projets et
ajoutez du contexte du lors le plus
intéressant est que dans la bande
annonce
il semble que nous soyons face à
l'organisation ultimatum du vilain flax
mâcheurs comme son nom l'indiqué c'est
un ennemi qui est contre tout ce qui est
nationalisme patriotisme pays et c'est
ce qui est un petit peu l' inverse du
symbole qu'est captain america en soi et
c'est là où c'est intéressant puisque
steve rodgers a stoppé ses fonctions
donc les actions terroristes se font
plus fréquentes notamment par le biais
de l'organisation ou ultimate all le but
de la série sera donc que sam
réussissent à devenir le nouveau captain
et porter ce fameux bouclier par rapport
au baron zemo que nous pensions tous
être l'ennemie de la série il se
pourrait comme on en avait parlé dans
une vidéo dédiée que le baron soit
plutôt une sorte d'alliés pour notre duo
de super un an plus tard black widow
retente sa chance pour le 7 mai 2021
je ne vais pas vous cacher que la petite
hype que j'avais pour ce film s'est
totalement éteinte mais le problème
surtout elle est ce qu'il sortira
vraiment pour 2 mai 2021
je l'espère en tout cas pareil je ne
rentrerai pas trop dans les détails on
sait déjà à peu près tout sur le film et
on en avait parlé en vidéo
il est en tout cas le premier film de
2021 sur les trois prévues on enchaîne
sur du très très lourd avec la fameuse
série law qui malgré une bande annonce
bien stylé au final il n'y a pas tant de
grosses informations que ça on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler bien plus en
détail dans une future vidéo mais
évidemment nous sommes face un lockheed
une réalité alternative puisque les
erreurs des avengers a permis à lockheed
s'échapper avec le tc raked et donc
créer une autre histoire que celle
d'origine
la tva non pas la taxe
la times variance authority est une
sorte de police du temps et des réalités
elle va devoir gérer le cas de l'eau qui
est l'arrêté pour éviter qu'ils ne
créent un trop grand bazar comme l'a dit
kevin fait guy avec cette série marvel
se tente un nouveau genre est le
portrait est tout dessiné l'eau qui
semble en cavale il va certainement
s'échapper de la tva et sera poursuivie
h 24 je pense même que la tva lui
révélera la véritable histoire qu'ils
devaient suivre ce qui expliquerait un
lot qui avec une mentalité différente
mais ça reste de la simple spéculation
personnel ah oui la série prévue pour
mai 2021 du shanxi est prévue pour le 9
juillet 2021 et sera incarné par
l'acteur simulie us
le film racontera l'histoire de ce
fameux héros maître du kung fu et qui
affrontera le mandarin le leader du
groupe terroriste des dix anneaux qui
cache un certain mystère ce groupe on
l'avait déjà vu dans le tout premier
ironman pour ceux qui veulent savoir à
plus d'informations que ça mais je suis
curieux de voir ce super héros car il
n'a tout simplement pas de réelle super
pouvoirs je trouve ça intrigue ans
d'intégrer un tel héros après avoir eu
des ennemis comme danos avec les pierre
d'infini ou encore une captain marvel
surpuissante
donc c'est avoir été 2021 une série
d'animations avec un concept que j'adore
what if
et si peggy carter était devenu captain
america et s'ils hershey n'avait jamais
parlé du mc eu
bref vous avez compris une série qui je
pense sera très visuel et qui mettra en
lumière l'entité cosmique du gardien
soit the watcher une entité chargée de
surveiller le déroulement de l'histoire
et qui nous permettra d'accéder à des
réalités différentes
je vous avoue que dans le concept
l'aspirine peut être canon on va dire
pour le mc eu car on sera sur des
histoires alternatives mais qui nous
permettront de montrer des choses
importantes voir des choses
croustillantes pour l'avenir du mc eu un
automne 2021 la série sur miss marvel
devrait voir le jour tout comme au
rwanda vision la série est là pour
ajouter du contexte et introduire
l'héroïne dans le mca avant de pouvoir
lancer captain marvel de karoui miss
marvel sera présente dans le film c'est
une héroïne fans de carole denver je
vous avoue que la série sera très
adolescente je pense mais traitera de
thématiques très pertinentes et
d'actualité
restons curieux certainement le film le
plus ambitieux et le plus attendu de
2021 concernant le mc u est prévue pour
le 5 novembre
zee est un os nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler dans des vidéos dédiées
internal ce nous proposera un nouveau
groupe de super héros avec un casting
énormes et se déroulant sur plusieurs
milliers d'années d'histoire
pour rappel les éternels sont une très
ancienne race issue de manipulation des
célestes sur le genre humain
les célestes sont des entités cosmique
très très ancienne que l'on pourrait
presque considérer comme des dieux et
font partie de la jeunesse de l'univers
et ont déjà été en contact avec galactus
le potentiel nouveau super vilains de la
phase bien évidemment les ennemis des
éternels seront l'est d'evian qui sont
aussi des humains qui ont subi une
manipulation des sélects
mais nous y reviendrons en temps voulu
17 novembre 2021 le légendaire spider
man qui fait couler beaucoup d'encre
récemment je vous avoue que je ne vais
pas vous dire grand chose au sujet de ce
film car je suis en train de préparer
une grosse vidéo sur le sujet est en
très bonne compagnie d'ailleurs une
compagnie que vous connaissez bien
on y retrouvera bien évidemment notre
cher tom holland un héros qui prend de
plus en plus de poids dans l'univers du
mc puis on termine 2021 avec hawk eye
qui nous proposera une expérience plutôt
particulière puisque kate michotte sera
de la partie et devra reprendre le
flambeau d'oeil de faucon apparemment
hawkeye aurait subi un accident qui le
rendrait sous
due aux actions de the cloud un nouvel
ennemi que le duo devra affronter dans
la série aux cayes étant sourd sa
capacité larcher est nettement touché et
qu'elle me chope sera donc formée nous
aurons apparemment également la venue de
la nouvelle venue noire incarnée par lj
elena belova que nous retrouverons dans
le film de black widow
nous verrons d'ailleurs je pense
beaucoup d'éléments par rapport à
l'évolution du shield du statut
d'occagnes etc
on arrive enfin à 2022 avec le film que
j'attends le plus docteur strange n
multivers of madness
rien de bien nouveau par rapport à ce
que nous savons déjà nous aurons le
retour de bordeaux christine palmer et
c'est néanmoins la seule info très
pertinente et que le film est
directement liée à spider man 3 nous
sembleront être face un mini avengers
entre spider man dr strange rwanda ou
encore vision mais on en reparlera dans
la vidéo de spider man 3 je compte sur
vous pour votre présence si mais 2022
tort love and thunder le casting a été
dévoilée et le grand méchant du film
également gore le massacreur de dieu
cela promet d'être clairement hype
surtout qu'il sera jouée par christiane
bails connu pour son rôle de batman dans
la trilogie dédiée gore est en gros
quelqu'un qui croyait beaucoup en les
dieux comme tort par exemple mais qui
n'a jamais reçu une des deux quand il en
avait besoin
donc maintenant il est un petit peu
malade et il veut du sang je vous résume
grossièrement la chose entre évolution
du personnage de thor passage de pouvoir
à jane foster qui va devenir une tort
féminine ou encore voir comment walkyrie
va gérer le peuple des asgardiens ça
promet clairement 8 juillet 2022
black panther 2 je ne rentrerai pas trop
dans les détails car c'est plutôt
compliqué pour le moment d'expliquer ce
qu'il se passera dans le film chadwick
bosman nous a malheureusement quittés
cet été et kevin fait guy a décidé de ne
pas réattribué le rôle à quelqu'un
d'autre et je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose
chadwick était iconique en black
panthères nous serons certainement face
à la perte du roi du wakanda dans black
panther 2
et nous auront possiblement un passage
de flambeau une sorte d'élection d'un
nouveau dirigeant
mais nous y reviendrons 11 novembre 2022
film que j'attends beaucoup et dont nous
avons déjà parlé plusieurs fois
captain marvel 2 le film mettra en
lumière miss marvel aux côtés de carole
denver ainsi que le personnage de monica
rambo qui apparaîtra également dans one
la vision monica est en quelque sorte
une captain marvel secondaire avec des
pouvoirs similaires et très liés à
l'héroïne
carole et non la drogue je précise
projet particulier donc je ne sais pas
vraiment comment prendre les gardiens de
la galaxie relie days parole prévue pour
le 25 décembre 2022
un préquelle au gardien la galaxy 3 je
pense que nous sommes dans le même
concept que pour les série préquelle au
grand film ce téléfilm balancera du
contexte et de nouvelles informations
tout en innovant avant de rentrer
vraiment dans les gardiens 3 prévu pour
il ya également la présence d'une série
dédiée à baby groupe du nom de iam route
une série particulière plus pour le fun
je pense où nous verrons les aventures
de big route
donc pendant la période pré infinity
ward je suppose babe ruth sera amené à
rencontrer de nouveaux personnages et
d'autres plus particulier que nous
connaissons déjà
je pense pouvoir affirmer que nous
allons rentrer dans la phase 5
avec ces merveilleux projets annoncés
les 4 fantastiques deadpool 3 blade ou
encore mutants ces quatre projets sont
hors mc hu à la base et on est tous
impatients d'enfin avoir ses héros dans
l'univers le plus intrigant et que
deadpool ne sera pas un reboot ce qui
sous-entend qu'il va clairement changé
de monde
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler mais
tous ces projets sont enfin clairement
officialisé rien de nouveau concernant
she hulk ou encore moon knight mais
quatre nouvelles séries sont prévues
i'm good dont je viens de parler
secretin vdn une thématique que je
trouve mes gars importante et que je
soupçonnais d'arriver dans captain
marvel de l'invasion secrète des scroll
sur terre sera finalement dans une série
dédiée
le casting pour le moment se compose de
nick fury est à l'os cela sous-entend
que captain marvel est absente est à
l'os sur terre du coup donc il
semblerait qu'on soit sûr du post
endgame et post far from home et enfin
iron art et armor wars 2 séries qui
tourneront autour de tony stark et qui
permettront de faire revivre le
personnage plus longtemps iron art
semble être la véritable héritière de
tony stark
riri williams est une adolescente fans
de technologie et qui a créé une armure
aussi avancé voire plus que celle que
tony a déjà créé le monde a besoin d'
iron man et riri en a conscience
possiblement lié à iron ore art et non
lionheart armor wars à traite du
problème que la technologie de tony
tombent entre de mauvaises mains ou art
machine semble être le protagoniste
principal de ce projet et possédant sa
propre armure et étant très lié à toni
ou encore peppers il pourrait agir en
tant que mentor pour iron racht via
cette série un nouveau passage de
flambeau
il y a tellement de nouvelles annonces
que j'ai oublié de mentionner également
entre man 3 cantou magna enfin nous
allons rentrer dans du sérieux avec le
chant quantique
ça fait un moment que je vous le dit
antoine est clairement sous côté et la
gang le conquérant un méchant ultra
iconique a été officialisé pour être le
grand méchant qui va se mesurer face à
antoine
pas de date de sortie prononcer pour le
moment cela sous-entend clairement 1
2023 donc bref on aura sûrement
également
rôle important pour cassis lang qui a
bien grandi pendant la période où thanos
avait effectué le snap
et voilà qui conclut avec toutes ces
annonces ce fut conséquent mais enfin de
la hype quoi ça fait du bien quand fin
2020 on voit qu'il ya un avenir plutôt
radieux concernant marvel et donc le mc
eu on a enfin des choses à se mettre
sous la dent et vous du coup quel projet
vous hype le plus moi je vous avoue que
pour le moment c'est vraiment dr strange
spider man 3 et 10 eternal skim hype le
plus qui m'attire le plus pour le moment
comme je vous disais au début de la
vidéo du coup vous êtes nombreux à
regarder les vidéos sur la chaîne sans
être spécialement abonnés donc n'hésitez
pas à le faire vous ne louperez plus
aucune une nouvelle vidéo est évidemment
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus allez c'était targo rock et que
iron art soit allez ciao tout
[Musique]